we consider the work done by a
gravitational force that's which was
path independent now let's generalize
that to any force between two points I
and another point F that if the work
done in going from the initial point to
the final point this is path independent
then we call this force a conservative
force
now conservative there are many
conservative forces that will analyze in
this class examples will be the
inverse-square electric force or the
gravitational force we've already seen
gravitational force near the surface the
earth is conservative spring forces are
other examples of conservative forces
but let's look a little bit in detail
suppose we call this path one and we
consider a second path path two then a
property of conservative forces is that
the work done is independent of that
path so if we total up the work from the
initial to the final on path one of F
dot d s and then we go from the final
point to the initial point on path 2 of
F dot d s then because these integrals
are independent of the path and all
we've done is shifted the endpoints is
we get zero and that's the statement and
we'll write W conservative here for
conservative forces so we're gonna call
this force conservative if it's path
independent so what we have here is the
statement that the work done by a
conservative force now what we'll do
here is indicate a circle by a closed
path that the work done by a
conservative fourth force on a closed
path is zero what does that closed path
look like well remember what we did was
we went from one but then instead of
going in
this direction we came back on path to
from the final to the initial point and
if the force is conservative the work
done around the closed path is zero